- [Andy] Good morning.
Thank you all for attending NET331,
AWS Cloud WAN MCP server.
I'm Andy, you can probably
guess with a photos,
who's who with Jose.
We really want to try and make
this an interactive session.
Rather than just fly through slides,
I'd like to try and take opportunities to,
for you to ask questions.
But you're not gonna escape,
we've got questions too.
So just before we kind of get into this,
I'd be really interested to know,
just with a quick show of hands,
from an audience perspective, who is into,
or is doing like core
networking, core AWS networking?
Okay, and then who's doing
more sort of DevOps work?
Now obviously my mass is
terrible and trying to gauge it.
Who's doing both?
Okay, all right.
So what's really nice to
see is over the last couple
of WAN events that who's
doing both is really changing.
We're getting more and more people now
starting to get involved in both sides,
which is a massive win.
So how did we get here?
What actually happened with this.
I'm gonna go forward a slide
and then go back a slide,
is I ended up having a
network similar to this,
very similar to this that I
was trying to troubleshoot
and as you can tell,
it's a complex network.
Dual core networks, multiple regions,
inspection VPCs, network function groups,
you name it, it's got it.
And going through this
meant that it was very,
very time consuming, and
going through each element
was very error prone just to
work out how do they get to be.
What tools did I have to hand?
Well, for my sins,
I'm far too stubborn to
have an idea about something
and then not at least try
and get to the end of it
and make it work.
Plenty of coffee and maybe
a little help from Gen AI.
I think the other thing
which became really,
really helpful is collaboration.
So I was very lucky to
be able to collaborate
with Jose on this rather than
doing it all on your own.
It's really good to get
a different perspective
and just someone else
to say, hey, hang on,
have you thought of this?
And I think that made a
massive, massive difference.
Of course we've been
through the network of hell,
which I will call it.
What options did I have initially
to try to put all these
pieces of the puzzle together
so I could quite easily work
out paths between A and B?
Well, AWS console, you
know, clickops are fine
but unfortunately I've
got a terrible memory
so I'll never remember where things are.
And also, it's very hard to repeat.
I think the console and clickops are great
to learn a new service.
AWS CLI, if you start
scripting the AWS CLI,
it can be quite powerful.
But again, I tended to end up having lots
and lots of more complex AWS CLI commands
now stitching together
with a a shell script,
and it just became very brittle
and not particularly pleasant.
And then Python, using Boto3.
I'm certainly no developer, but Gen AI,
if you're using an augmented
agent to help you with coding,
they're very good at coding.
And one of the things
that I have found is that,
if you make a good stab at something
and then you will ask
your agent of choice,
in this case it'll be Kiro to say, look,
why is this not working
and why is yours working?
And then gimme some output,
actually provide some
markdown explaining it.
And as you'll see later on in the slides,
I'm a massive fan of markdown
together with mermaid diagrams
and it really gives you some
good sort of study material.
So the strategic goal
was to create something
that all of those who put their hands up
for being a kind of core network
engineer takes for granted
is trace route.
So I just really wanted to see, look,
from A to B, how do I get
there, what's in the path?
Not just from a routing perspective
but also security controls
that might stop that connectivity.
But rather than try and eat
the proverbial elephant whole,
break it down into some smaller tasks.
For example, I'm not gonna
read them all out there,
but break those out into
more manageable tasks.
Use python scripts to
try and achieve that,
get some help with an agentic coding agent
and then start taking
these discreet scripts
and then putting them towards an MCP.
A good example for me was
creating a Python script
that essentially found your
global networks in your account,
your core networks, all
of your route tables.
I am obsessed with the
rich library from Python.
It's gotta be colorful and therefore,
print out each of those route tables
so I can really easily
see, look in each region,
in each core network, these
are the route or the prefixes
in each of those route tables.
So from here I wanna pass over to Jose
to start talking more about kind of agents
and the delineation
between agents and scripts.
- [Jose] Yes.
Before we get to the
actual code demonstration,
let's take a moment to talk
about AI agents and MCPs
so that we all understand what those are.
So AI agents are
applications that can reason
and plan and try to accomplish a goal
by leveraging LLM to do that.
And they can also act
meaning that they can call
for example, external APIs
to get more information
to accomplish this particular goal.
And these applications are
something that either you
or someone else has created.
If we look a little bit deeper,
what actually happens in the application
and there is something
we call agentic loop
and this whole process
starts when it gets an input.
So you invoke the agent
and you give it some prompt
and this is the goal that
the agent tries to achieve.
The agent takes this input or the goal
and all of the information
that was given to the agent beforehand,
so this would be like the
persona or any other information,
and also all of the tool
information that it has access to,
two MCPs, for example.
The agent sends all of
this information to LLM
and then the LLM starts
the reasoning process
that can it accomplish the goal
with this information that it has.
If the goal is something simple
like what is an IPV four address,
it most likely can find the information
from its training data and
answer back immediately.
If it is something that it
doesn't know, for example,
where is this IP address
located in my AWS environment?
It needs to do something else
and it'll go to the tool information
and try to find a tool that
can get this information to it.
The LLM then sends the
control back to the agent
with a specific syntax
specifying that it wants to use a tool
with particular augments.
The agent, the application
calls for example the MCP
and utilizes the tool
there with the augment
and gets the results back
after it has finished,
and then the loop starts again.
So all of the information,
the previous information
and now the new information
is sent back to the LLM
and the LLM starts the reasoning again
that does it now have enough
information to answer.
If the IP address was not found,
it might continue the loop
and for example, call the
tool again with different set
of augments like another AWS region.
Or if the IP address was found,
it can generate the final answer
and return back to the user that yeah,
the IP address was found.
And the MCP, which is short
for model context protocol,
it is an open source protocol
developed by Anthropic
and it provides a standardized way
for us to connect AI models
to external data sources and tools.
And it's yeah, very
widely used at the moment
and of course used in the network MCP
that we are demonstrating today.
In the AI agent that for
example, you have created,
you would have an MCP client running
that can then connect to MCP servers
that might be running on your
laptop or somewhere remote.
Let's take another show of hands.
How many of you are
currently using scripts
to manage your AWS network?
Okay, how many of you are
using AI at the moment
to manage the network?
There are a few, not that many yet.
Hopefully we can change that.
But yeah,
both of these are still
perfectly valid approaches.
Scripts are very good in scenarios
where you already know what
you want to get as an output.
So for example, if you
want to find the IP address
and you know how your network is built,
you can just use a script
and get the same answer
every time, and it's fast.
But then again, if the
question is something
that is more complex or
you don't exactly know
what you're going to be asking,
then AI is a really good tool for that.
So for example, if you want to ask that
can the EC2 instance
that owns that IP address
reach internet, and you might
have a complex network, so...
And we will see this
in the demonstrations.
In the demo today, we will
be using a live environment
and this is the environment.
If you have any questions
during the presentation,
we can try to do something live also.
But behind the scenes there
is a AWS cloud WAN network
with two a plus transit
gateways, some VPCs
and AWS network firewalls in the mix.
But yes, let's go into the code.
- [Andy] So I think just before
we go on to the code itself,
it's probably a good opportunity,
has anyone got any questions
or any thoughts at the moment
that you want to ask?
Wow, okay.
All right, I'm gonna coax
a question outta someone
at some point.
- [Jose] Can you switch over to the code?
- [Andy] Yeah.
- [Jose] Yes.
So today we will be using
Kiro CLI as our AI agent
and let's load that up.
It will be initializing two MCP servers.
We will be using the
AWS network MCP server
and there is also AWS knowledge
MCP server available for us.
And the first thing is,
I will be switching to a predefined agent.
So as I was mentioning in the start,
so when we are sending the
information to the LLM,
we can have some information
in the AI agent itself.
So here we have specified some
more detailed information,
what the agent should do and
some networking examples there.
And we can also take a look at the tools
so we can see that here is the
enterprise network MCP server
and the tools that are
available to us at the moment.
And before going into the
demonstration, let's take a moment
and look at the code that
is behind the scenes.
And this is one tool that is
within the network MCP server
and all of this has been built
with the FastMCP framework.
So the first tool that we are looking is
get cloud WAN details,
a pretty simple function
but this gives us possibility
to look at the structure,
how it has been built.
So there are four arguments in this tool
with two of our mandatory ones.
So core network ID, core network region.
Core network ID is the
ID which we want to get.
The core network region is
one of the key design choices
that we did for this MCP.
So we wanted to be able
to switch between regions
and accounts as easily as possible,
so all of the tools have this
region capability within it.
So the LLM can decide that it will call,
for example, US West two, E North one
or any other region that is available.
The third augment is next token
and this controls pagination
for core network attachments.
There are basically two design
choices that we could take,
either do the pagination
internally within the tool
and return everything immediately,
or then let the LLM control
if it wants to get more information.
And for this particular tool
we have taken the approach
that, okay, the LLM can decide
when it wants to have more
attachments given to it.
And lastly, there is the profile name.
As mentioned, we want to
control or keep the LLM control
to go to different accounts
so it can use the AWS CLI name
profiles to switch accounts.
Also important information
is the description.
So we are using pedantic
and the description field
is one of the details
that is sent to the LLM when
it starts to do the reasoning,
which tool to use and
how to use those tools.
So the description set for the augments
is an important detail also.
Moving on we have the
dockstring for the tool
and this is again one
of that information set
that will be sent to the LLM
so that it knows how to use it.
We will first give some
high level information
that you can use this tool
to get the cloud WAN core
network configuration and state.
We have also given information
when to use this tool.
So for example, when the LLM is doing
or asked to do troubleshooting
or understand network topology,
and this is part when we
were testing out these tools,
how to create this, that
this really makes a change
how well the LLM can execute.
For example, in complex scenarios
when it's doing path tracing
and it needs to use
multiple different tools.
There is also information
workflows and for example,
depending on the tools
there might be a lot more
information in the workflows
that after calling this tool,
what are the most potential next tools
that would give it good
enough information.
So for example, here it's
stating that get cloud WAN routes
or detect cloud WAN inspection
might be good approaches after this one.
And finally, we are specifying
what information will be returned.
So it's returning a dictionary
containing the core network information,
live policy, et cetera.
Then the actual code itself
kind of basic Python code.
So we are using repository library
for this to get access to the AWS APIs.
We have a help permit to get AWS client,
which we will be using
to switch between regions
and get the actual repository client.
If there is next token specified,
we will just get the list of attachments
and return immediately
those attachment details
and the potential next token.
But then the core network
policy and attachments,
that is also one design choice
that we did with this tool,
is that we don't want to
create individual tools
for individual API calls.
There are other a plus MCP servers
that you can use for that.
So we try to combine and make
the obstruction level higher.
So for each of the tools
it would actually do multiple API calls,
get more information immediately,
and keep that back to the LLM.
It makes the, for example,
troubleshooting analysis faster
because there are fewer tool calls
and also makes it more
efficient from processing wise
because we don't need to
send the information back
and forth for the LLM all the time.
And then for all of these tools
we are capturing all of the exceptions
and we are not handling
those within the code,
but we are raising all of
the errors back to the LLM.
So we are using tool error
from the FastMCP framework,
and for each of the error we
are specifying some details
like for example there was an error,
getting the a plus core network details.
We will also give it some
information what to do next slide.
For example, validate
parameter information
and this might depend on the actual tool,
what information we are giving back.
And then we are also sending
the full error back to the LLM
so that it can then
reason what to do next.
So if there was for example,
error with the sign in to
the AWS or something else.
And lastly if everything was good,
we will return back to
core network policy,
live policy and attachments.
Let's do one demonstration.
So we have our agent and
as we saw from the tool,
we need to give it the information
of the core network ID.
We don't know it at the moment.
So what we need to do
first is, for example,
list the current networks that we have.
So we can ask, list the core
networks in US West two,
what we might have available in this,
using a tool called list core networks.
And it found out that
there is one core network
in US West two with
just basic information.
So we know the core network ID and state,
but nothing else at the moment.
We can also ask to get more details
and now hopefully it'll use
the get cloud WAN details.
And after this call,
we are now actually getting more details
of the core network.
So it's you creating the basic
information in the start,
what is the name, ID, and its date.
It's also starting to passe
through the core network policy.
So for example, information
what edge locations we have,
what are the ASN numbers,
segment information,
which segments we have and which regions.
And also more details for example,
from network function
groups, and egress control
and the VPC attachments,
or all of the attachments
that we have specified.
And if we would want, we could then go in
and ask more questions, for example,
more detailed question on the attachments,
what each of the attachments
are and so forth.
But what I want to show here
also is the error handling.
So what if we ask something
that is not there?
So if we for example ask
to get one core network,
but that we know that is not valid.
Okay, that shouldn't be there,
it is again calling tool,
and now we get the error back
that the core network ID is invalid
and the core network must be
following a specific pattern.
And this is the reason why
we didn't want to handle
all of the errors in the code,
but actually keep those back to the LLM.
So now the LLM can give us
more information that yeah,
the idea was wrong and for example,
do we want to use the valid core network
that it already knew or something else?
For example, list more networks.
- [Andy] So we're gonna move on to,
let me just click PowerPoint,
MCP and agent files.
But before we move into
that, just one thing
that I kind of really wanted to emphasize.
A design decision was
taken really early on.
So Jose's gone through a couple
of the tools that were used,
you know, live demos, demo
goods have been good so far,
but this really comes into
scripting versus using an MCP.
The idea was to use the
actual agent and the LLM
for the decision making not turn an MCP
into this giant script
where all the logic is
built within the script.
So the tools and any
tool training that's done
will pass the information
back to the agent.
The agent will then use
the LLM to make decisions
as to what to do next.
And I think that's something
that is a really important
paradigm to remember.
Otherwise you do end up
building out this huge script,
basically that just
happens to be called MCP
and the differences are
stark in the results.
Now for the keen eyed of
you, you may have noticed
that when Jose went into Kiro,
actually there was a small
line on there saying,
AWS network agent,
why are we using an
agent as well as an MCP?
So what we found through
a lot of trial and error
and also trying to build
some of the additional logic
into the MCP that makes it
become huge and quite complex,
is to actually use an
agent file I should say.
It doesn't actually alter the capabilities
or the functionality of the MCP server,
but it does give you a few things
that are very, very useful.
Not just for this MCP server,
but literally for any.
It'll give you a stable persona.
So in this example, AWS network MCP,
we gave it the persona
of a network engineer.
So the the typical kind of
rules that an MC, sorry,
that a network engineer should follow.
We gave like a tool usage policy,
you know, when to use which tools
and provided some more guided prompts
to provide specific
outcomes that we wanted.
What we really found from this then
is that the agent itself
has a context first,
so it looks at the context
before it starts making calls.
It orchestrates those workflows
and it will provide some sort of overrides
and specialization in terms
of knowledge and prompting.
So the same queries or prompts
that were given to the MCP
server would've worked.
It's just that by using an agent
we get back exactly what we
want in the format we want it.
So it gives us a lot more control
over the kind of how the MCP works
and the data that we get back.
So from here we're gonna
go on to some videos
that they actually will
do some demo, so...
Go for it.
- [Audience Member] The tool
that you called network,
is that a custom tool or is
that something that I do.
- [Andy] I do apologize I
didn't quite catch the foot.
- [Audience Member] You use
the tool called network, right?
To discover that?
- [Andy] Yeah.
- [Audience Member] That tool,
is that a custom made tool?
- [Andy] Yes, so the MCP that
we're talking about today
started life as cloud WAN MCP
because it was very geared
towards just AWS Cloud WAN.
But what we found is that,
if we wanted to do things
like trace route for example,
you know it goes through VPCs,
cloud WAN, network
firewall, transit gateway,
it touched on far more technologies
than you would find just in Cloud WAN.
So we renamed that as AWS networking MCP.
Now your question, just to
paraphrase so everyone can,
who may not have heard it,
was the core network tool,
is that a specialized tool?
Yes, so what you'll find
within the MCP server itself,
it consists of a number of tools
and those tools are written
specifically for that MCP server
and get core network
is a tool specific to the
AWS networking MCP server.
The AWS networking MCP server
was released yesterday.
So by all means, you can
go and have a look at it.
There'll be a link,
it's in GitHub, AWS labs
and you can actually walk through
and see all of the tools included
plus all the source code.
Ultimately, this is open source,
there's nothing proprietary about this.
Demo?
- [Jose] Yeah, you're gonna?
- [Andy] Yeah, okay.
- [Jose] Go ahead.
- [Audience Member] Question for ya.
- [Andy] Yep.
- [Audience Member] The
agent also, open source
that you have wrapped
around the MCP server?
- [Andy] So, well, the agent
that we're actually using here
is Kiro, for obvious reasons,
but we've also tested it
with TOR code, with VS code,
with kind of the usual suspects.
So the most commonly used agents,
we've tested it with
to make sure it works.
So it should work up with kind
of any standard coding agent.
What that coding agent
uses in the background.
You can choose, sometimes
you're limited in choice
but other times you can
choose the actual LLM itself
the agent's using.
So for this, what we're gonna do a demo,
lemme just quickly work
out where we are here.
- [Jose] Let's do it live I think.
- [Andy] Okay.
- [Jose] (indistinct).
- [Jose] Let's try.
- [Andy] So, what we're gonna do here is,
we're gonna go through
and one of the things,
look if you're using kind of a cloud WAN
or you're using any other network service,
IP addresses are pretty
much common to everything.
So where's my IP?
Someone gives you an IP
address, where is it?
So what we're gonna do is live
code a find my IP MCP server.
So just like when I started
originally doing this,
not being kind of from
a developer background,
I did use Kiro to kind of help
me create the initial Python
as a proof of concept to make
sure I can get what I need to.
So you can apply the same principle here
with putting in what
you want that MCP to do.
This is very specific,
it's finding an IP address.
So we've asked Kiro to
create an MCP server
to find an IP address
and given it some parameters around that.
Kiro will now go off and
kind of work its magic
and you'll see here what
it's actually creating.
It will create the find
IP address MCP server,
and going back to your question earlier,
it will create specific
tools in the MCP server
to find the IP address, and
there's some additional details
that it will find as part of the MCP.
What it'll then do, it will
also provide you the JSON
that you'll end up normally
putting in like, MCP.JSON
for example, which means
that we can actually,
once it's finished building
it, we can add it to the MCP
or JSON and try it live.
- [Jose] I need to get
the IP address, tool,
can't remember what the tool name was.
Tool AWS IP search with profile network.
- [Andy] So this shouldn't take too long.
Now because, 'cause they
didn't provide a a region
what the MCP will actually do,
it'll look at all of the
regions your count is opted into
and then use a parallel async function
to search all the regions and
then stop all of those threads
or all of those functions
once it finds it.
Otherwise it's gonna keep
searching all of them.
So you can see from here,
it's found the IP, the region,
the ENI that the IP address is
associated with, the subnet,
the instance that's
associated with that ENI,
and just saying that it's
a private IP address.
I mean that literally took what?
Three or four minutes to create.
Personally, well, I think
it's quite a helpful tool,
but that gives you an example of,
you don't have to be a
core Python developer.
One sec, a core Python developer
that's built MCPs in the past.
There's a really easy way to get started
using kind of an agentic coding assistant.
- [Audience Member] Now, that tool,
was it built to specifically
achieve that goal
of finding an IP address?
- [Andy] Correct.
- [Audience Member] Is that the approach
that you would recommend versus having MCP
to discover information
and then having the agent
trying to piece together the more generic,
find you VPCs in all
your different accounts
and things like that and then
coming up with that solution?
- [Andy] Yes.
Just to make sure everyone
kind of got the question,
and please correct me if I
paraphrase it incorrectly.
The tool here that was
built was very specific
to find an IP address,
and then provide some information
around the IP address.
When you're building a large MCP server,
is that the approach that
we would normally take
or would we look at building tools
that are far more generic?
I'll give you my view on this
and then also, hopefully
we've got a similar view
but I'll also pass over to
Jose to give his view on this.
So for MCP servers, if you
take a look at the source,
for example, of the AWS
networking MCP server,
you'll find that there's
a lot of tools in there.
So what we've actually done
is, there's kind of two ways
to do this is, use a
monolithic server up high,
which has got everything in it,
but that then starts to become
really big really quickly.
Or you can create logical groups
of tools in the file system
and dynamically load and register those
which is what we ended up doing.
So the tools that we've built
are to achieve a specific purpose.
So, find IP address,
find all of your core
networks in your account,
find your global networks,
find AWS network firewall and policies.
And then by giving the
information back to the agent,
and of course we've
used like an agent file
to give it some further direction.
What we should then do
is here say to the agent,
look, here's all the
information that we've got,
how should we proceed?
And then it will then
choose the tool training
to put in place for specific information
to almost analyze the hop by hop,
if you want to do trace route for example,
or if you've got a much more
complex question to ask it,
is how to break that down into subtasks
and choose the tools that it
should use to build that up
to achieve the bigger,
more complex picture.
- [Jose] If I expand on that,
we will see an example of path trace next.
But exactly when we
were creating this tool,
we tried to avoid too
specific tools and large tools
like path trace, we could
just write a script for that
but then it would be a script.
So we try to get or try to
hit some form of balance
that there is higher level of abstraction
but still that yeah, we
could get enough information
to achieve higher goals
or more complex goals.
- [Andy] And I think
the last thing on this,
is that it goes back to
something I said earlier is,
when you're using an MCP server
that's being used by an agent
that's got access to an LLM,
use that intelligence,
use the intelligence
and the capabilities
of the language model,
which is very good at
taking like tons of data in,
pulling out the data it needs,
and then doing something with it.
And we're gonna go through
path trace in a minute
or trace route and you'll
see that it touches
so many different technologies from AWS
that if you were to try
and build that into one
sort of big monolithic tool,
you'd have to cater for every use case.
Where what we are doing is,
by calling multiple specific tools,
getting the agent to make the decision
about what to do with
that and what to do next.
- [Audience Member] So,
specifically what defines
the IP address example
in that tool is that,
based on how you built it,
is that why we're getting that output?
And for example,
if I wanted to include
something like account ID,
would I have to build it into the tool
or would MCP have that context
if I were to ask that as well?
- [Andy] So because the
find IP address itself
has to look through the accounts,
look through the regions,
if you were to ask it
something that by doing
the kind of lookups that it's got to do,
would have the information to hand,
it will give you that information back.
If it's something that
hasn't got anything to do
with any of the lookups that
it's got, then it wouldn't.
- [Audience Member]
You'd have to build it.
- [Andy] Yeah.
And that's really why if you
build smaller, discreet tools
and then use the intelligence
of the agent/ LLM
to stitch those together,
you can get a lot more
flexibility from that.
So you could ask say, find this IP address
and show me the security groups
associated with the instance
and then obviously the
agent and the LLM would say,
I can find the IP now, what
tools have I got available to me
to find the security groups?
When we go through the videos here,
one thing I'm a massive, massive fan of,
not just for these MCPs
but just generally when
you're using an agent is,
get the agent to give
you a report in markdown
but also provide mermaid
diagrams to make things visual.
And you'll see why.
It really does give you
a lot of information.
So for this particular one,
do you wanna run the path trace first?
- [Jose] Yeah.
- [Andy] So what we'll do is,
we've got a recorded path trace
because it takes a long time
and we've cut out all the thinking parts.
So if we go onto the PowerPoint...
- [Jose] We get it from there.
- [Andy] Yeah, I just find the,
oh, you've got the clicker.
And I think this really
kind of brings it together.
Here we go.
Right, so what we've done here
is this is the path trace.
Now what we're doing from here is,
we're literally just saying
can you provide a path trace
between two IP addresses
using the AWS network MCP.
Now, this kind of reiterates
what we've kind of said
around small specific tools
that provide a specific output
that then can be used to train tools
and the intelligence is all
done by the actual agent
and LLM itself.
So what it's doing here is
it's going through a hop by hop
how you do a trace route normally,
which is, there we go.
Sorry my apologies, I've just
clicked in the wrong place.
Why is that not...
Here we go.
So you can see from here,
once it goes through
and it finds your source destination,
it runs through literally hop by hop
what your infrastructure composes of,
and will record all of this information.
Now what I've done at the end of this is,
the video's not playing particularly well.
I've asked it afterwards, please
can you provide me a report
in Markdown with mermaid diagrams
to explain what that
path trace looks like.
This is the path trace report.
Now again, whenever you're
doing a report with Markdown,
sorry, ask it to include
MCP, sorry mermaid diagrams
'cause it'll produce diagrams like this
that actually show you a breakdown of,
in this case the path trace,
exactly the path it took
and even puts a nice little emoji on there
to show an inspection VPC with a firewall.
But it'll literally walk
through each component
showing what's there, but then
it'll go into more detail.
Again, it's hard to see from here,
but it'll show you each of
those hops that it takes,
what that's composed of.
But from a network engineer
perspective, as we know,
the return path is equally as valid
because if it's not symmetric,
you're gonna have a problem.
Firewalls are not gonna play nicely.
So once it's done then,
if we keep going down,
it'll give you an overview
of what the cloud WAN
architecture itself looks like,
where the segments have got
used, network function groups
and if you keep going down,
then start showing you your route tables.
We can just kind of gradually
go through the rest of it
if you just scroll down through the rest,
if there's anything really pertinent.
So it'll also show your
security control analysis.
That's network ACLs for
anyone who uses them.
Firewall inspection VPCs,
does the policy allow that connectivity.
Any particular issues that are identified.
And it'll also show your security groups.
And then the nice thing is,
it'll give you a connectivity matrix.
Now this is nothing more than
saying provide a path trace.
Now because as we kind of
said before the questions,
that calls a lot of discreet tools
and each of those tools provides data.
What it's now doing is
it's taking all that data
and it's creating a
markdown report for you,
but it's using mermaid diagrams as well
to give you the visualization
where that really helps.
So I think on this one, what it also does,
it just provides you some CLI tools
if you want to not trust what it says,
and kind of validate for
yourself each of the hops itself,
it'll provide you the AWS CLI tools.
The next one.
- [Audience Member] Quick question.
- [Andy] Yeah, go for it.
- [Audience Member] On the
previous, on the slide you did
when you went through this,
you picking up this demo here,
it said that there was a
lot of trial and error,
any key learnings of what you tried
that we could learn from not to do?
Like when you were building
this (indistinct) tool?
- [Andy] Oh wow, oh wow.
Well first of all, when I had hair,
Yes, lots.
So I'll give you just a couple
of the ones that I found
that were really key and then,
'cause they obviously
add some more in there
because you've got a much
stronger development background
than I have.
So first of all, if you rely too much
on an agentic coding agent,
it ultimately did provide
a cloud WAN MCP server
that gave me what I wanted.
But it was really full of,
for want of a better term,
bloatware.
There was a lot of things in
there that it weren't needed,
it didn't clean up a few things properly
and it didn't give me a lot of control.
So the standard in the
AWS labs MCP servers,
bar this one, just
because of the size of it
were very much put
everything in server PY.
So you'd have kind of one monolithic file
with all the tools in.
And we soon found that,
once you start touching on
cloud WAN, VPCs, firewalls,
firewall policies, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera,
that that soon becomes huge.
And it also means that
it's not that extensible.
So by breaking that
down into logical groups
on the file system for cloud WAN tools,
network firewall tools,
it means that later on,
if you wanted to add some tools in
specifically for VPC endpoints for,
I can't think of anything
else, VPC Lattice,
you know, whatever the case may be,
you've got dedicated
tools within a directory
rather than forever expanding
this massive server PY.
So I think that was a key learning.
The other one was test with
real infrastructure often.
What I found is, when I
used mock infrastructure
or mock data to test with,
often it would be left in there
and then you'd say,
is this particular tool working properly?
Yeah, it's great look, it works perfectly.
And when you look closely,
it's just using mock data.
So I try to, this is just me,
I try to avoid using mock data
when I don't need to.
One of the benefits of
doing this in the cloud,
we can spin up a test environment.
If it's cloud WAN, please
then spin it down afterwards.
But you can test it against
a known good architecture,
just test often against something,
making sure you get the
responses you want every time.
- [Jose] Yeah, I think
that's one key learning also
was the error handling.
So as LLM tries to be
as helpful as possible
without good error handling
and good information
giving back that if something failed
that what it needs to do next.
And for example, validate.
So we have a lot of
information in the tools
and there is a specific tool, for example,
just for path trace that gives information
on the methodology what needs
to be done and in which order.
Without that it tries to be helpful.
And for example, if something fails,
it doesn't have access to
something or what it might be,
AI can just go past and say
that okay, everything is good
and it's working even though
it didn't actually verify it.
So think that the error handling
is one of the key details here,
just to make sure that you get that right.
- [Andy] I'm gonna add just
one last one on this is,
even before we started
using agent files on this,
we used an MCP resource
to provide a persona
to the MCP server.
Literally saying, you
are a network engineer
or network operations, and
these are the guidelines.
So if partial data
comes back or something,
a tool returns data that's not complete,
don't assume life is good
and everything's okay.
Stop, use the error
handling and report back.
Otherwise it can just la, la,
la it's all good, carry on.
And you've got a core
decision that's led you down,
potentially a very dark path
to try and troubleshoot.
Yes?
- [Audience Member] On
this markdown document,
there was a section that
said, "Issues identified."
Is that based on a general
guidance and best practice
or is that included as output
when you're trying to troubleshoot
a specific (indistinct)?
- [Andy] That's actually
included in the output
from the particular tool
that found where there
was a potential problem.
So that's further enhanced
when you use things like a
persona or you use an agent file
to give it very strict direction.
But generally, if the tool returns data
where it thinks there's a problem,
it will get there automatically.
So you don't have to go overboard
with regard to try and
thinking of every use case,
every corner case.
- [Audience Member] So it's proactively
identifying position.
- [Andy] Correct, correct.
- [Jose] I saw that there
were a couple more questions,
but due time I think that
we need to finalize this one
and if you have more questions
we will be around here after
the presentation, so...
- [Andy] Yeah, what I would
encourage just really quickly
is look, we're gonna be around.
Unfortunately we love
talking about this stuff,
so if you want to sit down over
a coffee and have a chat now
or anytime during the
week, just give us a shout.
Both of us would love to
sit down and talk with you,
connect offline.
So one of the tools that I
found was very, very useful
because trying to do
this manually is hard.
So I tried to explain
this to a customer once
and I wrote some Python to try and do it
and it was very difficult to do.
So the prompt that was
given to the MCP server was,
please explain the core network policies,
always plural in case
there's more than one,
explain the network function
group configuration,
if it exists.
And the almighty, please
include mermaid diagrams
where it's viable.
And as you can see from here,
it'll actually break down the policy.
It'll show you all of your segments.
The segments that are isolated,
the segments that have
got direct connectivity,
which you'll see here
because they've got
route sharing configured.
So it'll actually show you
not just which segments
have got connectivity,
but you'll have arrows on there
to show you the direction as well.
It'll build out a connectivity matrix.
And then the really handy thing is,
if you go down a bit further,
it'll actually explain to you,
sorry, just go up a little bit.
It'll explain to you why
certain routes are blocked.
So as well as giving you the
diagrams and the explanations,
it'll also say to you,
this is why things work
or this is why things don't work.
Now the hardest one is the next part,
is the network function group analysis.
So it'll take the network
function group configuration
in the policy and then
build out mermaid diagrams
to show you each of the
network function groups
and their capabilities.
So as we go down, you'll
see the attachments,
the patterns that each of
the attachments have got,
send to and send via.
And if you keep going
down a little bit further,
you'll start seeing that for each
of the network function groups,
you get that visual explanation
around how it works.
So if you are troubleshooting something
and you're not quite sure
if a network function group
is doing something specific,
you can actually look at the document,
which will give you a, I say a verbal,
a written explanation
of how it's configured,
but also provide mermaid diagrams
to show you how things are configured,
where things are blocked,
where connectivity is blocked by design,
where there's isolation.
Now getting that just from JSON document
that is returned from cloud
WAN is very difficult to do.
If you go down the last little bit,
it'll show you the configuration
of the network function group
and it'll give you some of the
information in JSON as well.
But using a question,
asking it to provide the
output in a markdown document
with mermaid diagrams will
save you so much time.
And for learning, incredibly helpful.
So as I said before, just
to kind of recap quickly
and we've got a few minutes for questions,
this started off as AWS
cloud WAN MCP server,
but after we realized that it touched
so many network services,
and the fact that we want
to make this extensible
to any network services,
we changed the name to
AWS network MCP server.
That's been released,
that's available today for folks to use.
It's open source, so if you're
doing something on path trace
or you are looking at
something about, I don't know,
getting the policy and you think,
I've got a really good
idea, do a PR, add to it.
You know, if you're doing
something on, I don't know,
a service that's not there already,
so say one of the services
that's being announced this week,
or VPC Lattice, or one of
the services you heavily use,
do a PR.
It'd be really good to
get community involvement.
So that's kind of it from
what we were going over today.